the astrophysicist and occasional
guitarist brian may joins us on the
programme brian it's great to see you
hope you're well um tell us just a
little bit about the album another world
why the decision to remaster and put it
back out there again
the main reason was that it just wasn't
available i realized that none of my
stuff from from that period was
out there not on spotify not on apple
music
not on youtube whatever and i just
thought this is something i'm proud of
it's part of me so let's go back and i
talked to the record company i've told
this story before i discovered i didn't
have a record company for my stuff
i hadn't even looked at this for so many
years but this is from 1989 and to me
it's still very relevant it's about
another world like a parallel universe
and it's a very emotional album because
i was going through some emotional stuff
at the time but i'm hoping that it
relates to people these days it's a
whole new generation that gets to see
this
it has optimism it has a search for
truth and a search for light
it has a lot of pain in it but i think
people relate to pain and i think
sharing pain is is a good part of music
so i wanted to put it out i want it to
be out there because i'm proud of it i
guess um always have been
there it is
it's another world
which is wonderful people your viewers
viewers may well be detecting uh you
know
subtle references to the world above us
the uh
outer space and the rest and of course
you've got the launch i think it's this
evening um one of my favorite places on
earth um the observatory over in
greenwich
i love it there yeah i'm very privileged
to be able to present it tonight 7 30
and what i'm doing is uh sharing it with
the world hopefully via my instagram
brian may for real and we're on my
instagram at the moment um so
neil if you want to say hi
hello
at the internet yeah we're also on tv
that's also still a thing remember
yeah we're not quite as big as sky news
you know but we're working on it yeah no
no no
so where where did these kind of twin
loves come of course you know
everyone knows by now shirley knows by
now about the phd in astrophysics but
but but more than that i mean there has
been a lifelong fascination hasn't that
same as myself i i cannot stop myself
from from from gazing up
yeah well it came from patrick moore i
think my dear friend patrick moore who
became a kind of adopted uncle to me i
used to beg my parents to be allowed to
stay up for as late as 10 o'clock to see
the sky at night and he presented that
show for 50 years which is a world
record
every time that music came on you see it
already it's linked
that stirring wonderful music that made
you feel like you were looking into the
cosmos i was hooked and i wanted to be
an astronomer and i wanted to be a
musician as well i actually wrote to
patrick
when i was a kid i must have been about
nine years old and what i asked him was
what is the music that your program
starts with and he wrote back on his
typewriter personally and said it's pele
arsene medicine by sibelius
at the castle gate and i rushed out and
bought the record i still have it and
it's been a great inspiration to me
music and astronomy
always do seem together to go together
it seems to me most of the famous
astronomers in history have been
musicians too including including isaac
newton
and we run a thing called starmus my
dear friend garrick israelian the
eminent armenian astronomer runs starmus
every year or a couple of years and it's
a combination of astrophysics
astronautics and music and it just it's
a rocket it's something great everybody
smiles the whole time well i'm i i
sincerely wish you very very well with
it enjoy yourself tonight you're back on
tour a little later this year i spoke to
adam lambert last year he's a star
anyway brian may and all your followers
on the internet thanks very much for
joining us really appreciate it thank
you neil god bless